hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
and we are here in sunny Barcelona to
wrap up 2016 it's been a crazy year of
legal legend so here are your top 10
best plays of the year I'm running away
but right over here looking brew cocoon
what's Bobby Bobby Flash's food easy
though
now sweat into the back lines who need
crying rampage there but it's getting it
set up and killed shut down but baby
here's photo shoot on me back in scoops
them all in and the models just get a
run wrapping in this team by Phoenix
blows up and builder goes off PO belters
is the house the notorious b.o.b strike
again
all of Team Liquid are right there for
the picking it how about there flash all
gets all members of Team Liquid and then
it's just clean up here who can whack
them all everybody's got a scramble Mike
went out this time around hoodie and
hawks are in a bit of a battle in hoody
knocking to the air to make this charm
and of course he's got a right for that
one with riposte
now who still in a bad spot knocked
around Janus
my word of mortals keep it alive they'll
kill yellowstar as well
adrian is a superhero at this point
though posture and spent both hit into
the wall they kick ho Beltre to the side
but that doesn't help whatsoever and at
that point it's a really angry ólafur
now teleport coming in the backline yes
funny looking for a kill this could be a
fight here plunder who's gonna lock down
he comes fine antlers but he gets old
and instantly by easy hood he is almost
going to go down but ella gets a massive
four man Paul Chryst Aldo who opted up
on the other side by long and fundraise
man who loves their stag going in with a
package butch Parisi who knew pops the
ulti endless massive positioning over
the side as they finally take down the
Bromberg Bee Gees go massive that's a
Quadra endless gets himself a pentakill
and what good positioning out of the ad
carry actually when you can keep mid
lane alive because top and hip has been
killed and they even got the pickoff on
bank rocks doesn't actually have to stop
pushing right now they can delay the
recalls - arrows
is dr. which me thinking
how much more can be done
take wolf running out of house
back with game Joe
didn't know where the lease in is so
they don't go for the play now maybe on
to Luba who was in trouble cocoon but he
gets off the slicing melter there's so
much David
gee we have to see replay Duke and Blanc
together jump onto lubricant to stun
both of you it's a lot of damage and
he's so low now with a look at a kick
I'm Alexi dis repositions gets the kick
off and then safeguards looper right
after and keeps him alive he's going to
deny the bat G - it's gonna be a long
but I think they can end the game
now he's alting into double Global's
paying off suddenly three members of G 2
are in the base and they're set to end
the game all they need to do is hit the
Nexus they're taking their time purse
running laps trying to dodge out the
bombs combo on the way in trying to
create the space necessary expense
allows one light he just needs to are
they going to be offended who's gonna
take one more Auto be kidding me
ladies survive Berk suddenly such a
massive shield Trek he doesn't care
about the fight he's moving in doubles
easy rod in the back trying to stall out
the pressure 50 throwing down autos as
well we'll hit are they here all it
takes is a single take double kill for
police though members are dropping left
and right trick he is too tanky no way
left are you kidding me
[Applause]
oh my god bye Tony
they mean the time to be back an agent I
mean eight seconds own Oh purse here
let's find out I think Mercy's got a
spawn
let's see 70 horsepower intakes takes a
while to tear to these towers here but
now the grooves here it's gonna lower
the resistance this time finish on
seconds this is the final team oh my god
what a game coming haft of course they
have no need to find on matzo can they
do it lame just by getting tired I
should say six-day does get monta the
dragon goes down it's secured by x50
that is before God then they quit good
man you believe don't you have the faith
HCl G because they just secured three
look I gotta go looking for it and can
they end on this one I've never done it
up I never down at down have no need to
find on matzah can they do it lamb just
fight dragon ain't dyin I should say
stick say does get monta the dragon goes
down and secured by x50 that is my god
can you believe do you have the faith
he's gonna die is now dandy turns up the
Bengals rain is going to fall cavemen
can he get in there swaysway no get out
of the wheels pavement will he do it
easier easy any be the hero takes down
icon SMLC it's gonna get rid of Dendi
splashes easyhoon can he do it he does a
game and she young now gonna try and
fight him zhonya's comes through to
avoid the occasion surprise and now be
she after a pentakill for easyhoon to
win this game they have double mountain
breaks it speaks to their strengths of
being able to burst out the bear and
they're hoping to get wrong to pull
kocha call and wish you've already been
used a trick is running away expect gets
caught down he's gone
chiju
the best timing ever seen on a Canada
that was insane the best top laner as
TSM still have to in we're all Weaver's
all about a couple now can they have the
follow-up damage a couple of stones come
in they've got Dixon and they shut up
that with a 1600 damaged spring can
Hogan double blow meteos another knock
of tracers - at the lucas ugh
kill you all kill everybody they've got
three if that goes down and haze for TSM
double lift towards around the fight
staying alive so much patience bides his
time right about the very end they get
the critical kill onto bjergsen and they
see double left low but he had saved the
heal something that doublelift says so
often keeps on baiting at extremely low
health saves his defensive cooldowns for
that last second to draw you in and then
the counter-attack from and the heart
breaker for me was watching and there
you have it do you agree with our list
or do you feel like we actually miss
something
let us know in the comments below I'm
Lisa from the score eSports and we will
see you guys next year
[Music]
you